Over the course of a decade and change, Michael
C. Hall starred on two of the most critically
acclaimed television series in recent memory,
both of them about death.
He played David Fisher on HBO's family-run
funeral home drama Six Feet Under, and then
vigilante serial killer Dexter Morgan on Showtime's
Dexter.
Between the two shows, Hall amassed six Emmy
and five Golden Globe nominations—and one
Golden Globe win—for his performances.
"Yea, well the tricky thing, the tricky thing
about Dexter is that I look so much like him."
But with the end of Dexter in 2013, Hall has
been largely absent from TV.
Here's a look at what he's up to in the past
few years.
Curtain call
Hall is an experienced theatrical actor.
After completing the Graduate Acting program
at New York University's prestigious Tisch
School of the Arts, Hall landed the plum role
of the Emcee in director Sam Mendes' 1999
revival of Cabaret on Broadway.
While on a hiatus from Six Feet Under in 2002,
he portrayed shady lawyer Billy Flynn in the
long-running revival of the musical Chicago.
When Dexter concluded in 2013, Hall again
had the time to return to the stage.
One of his most notable roles was in Hedwig
and the Angry Inch, a glam-rock musical about
an East German transgender wannabe rock star.
Hall was the third actor to play the title
role on Broadway, following Neil Patrick Harris
and Andrew Rannells.
Channeling Bowie
Hall's next major theatrical role was Thomas
Newton in Lazarus, a musical co-created by
David Bowie just before his death in 2016.
Built around previously existing Bowie songs
as well as ones that had yet to be released,
Lazarus was presented by the New York Theatre
Workshop from late 2015 to early 2016.
Hall reprised his role when the sold-out show
moved to London.
When Bowie died unexpectedly just before the
Lazarus cast recorded the show's album, Hall
said that he felt an "internal fist clench."
But the cast decided to continue the work
in his honor.
"We were glad we were able to get together
and celebrate his life by recording the album."
Voice work
Outside of stage and screen, Dexter has used
his vocal talents to do some voice work here
and there.
Hall has had a recurring role on the light-hearted
Disney XD sci-fi/fantasy series Star vs. the
Forces of Evil.
In what's probably Hall's most comic role
to date, he voiced an evil reptile man named
Toffee.
"Eat something.
It could be your last meal."
A little closer to his wheelhouse of dark,
brooding, men: Hall played Batman in Justice
League: Gods and Monsters...with some lines
that'll probably bring on deja vu for Dexter
fans.
"He bled to death"
"Yes, except they can't find the blood."
Indie movies
Since the end of Dexter, Hall has popped up
in a handful of low-profile but critically-acclaimed
independent films.
He starred in Cold in July, taking the role
of a man who kills a burglar, and then must
deal with the man's father, who's out for
revenge.
Hall followed up that screen role with yet
another project revolving around death: Christine,
about a deeply unstable Florida news anchor.
Michael C. Hall played George, a potential
love interest and fellow news anchor.
Married life
In February 2016, Hall took some time to catch
up on his personal life.
At New York City Hall, he and Morgan Macgregor,
his partner of four years, tied the knot,
which marked Hall's third trip down the aisle.
In the early 2000s, he married his Chicago
co-star, actress Amy Spanger, and later got
hitched to Jennifer Carpenter, who played
his sister, Deb, on Dexter.
Radiohead: Obsessed
"You're free until you've had enough And you
don't understand No ripcord."
In 2016, Hall and fellow Hedwig and the Angry
Inch star Lena Hall teamed up to perform at
a Radiohead tribute concert called "Radiohead:
Obsessed."
The band they formed was a one-time only thing,
turning out a performance at New York's Café
Carlyle.
The songs they played included "Ripchord"
from Radiohead's 1993 debut LP Pablo Honey,
as well as a mash-up of songs from Radiohead's
1995 follow-up The Bends.
Upcoming projects
Hall will be back on screens, big and small,
very soon.
Over the last couple of years, he's filmed
appearances in three high-profile projects.
Hall has joined the second-season cast of
Netflix's Queen Elizabeth II drama The Crown,
portraying President John F. Kennedy.
Another project, The Silent Man, is a thriller
about the Watergate scandal starring Liam
Neeson as Mark Felt, the high-ranking FBI
official who leaked details of the scandal
to the Washington Post under the name "Deep
Throat."
In that film, Hall has a major role as John
Dean, the lawyer who served as White House
Counsel during the sinking Nixon administration.
And finally, he's slated to appear in The
Gettysburg Address, a documentary about President
Abraham Lincoln's most famous speech.
Sounds like there's life after Dexter after
all!
"I have nothing to hide.
Except for the syringes, scalpels, and bone
saw hidden in that secret drawer underneath."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!